can bitcoin save you from inflation
bitcoins fans love the idea of using
cryptocurrency as a hedge against
hyperinflation
in fact the original white paper which
serves as the founding document for the
whole asset class specifically talks of
a phase when no coins will be created
and it will become inflation free but is
this really possible can bitcoin truly
abolish the cycles of hyperinflation in
human history that seem money returned
to the value of the paper they printed
on in places as diverse as germany
zimbabwe and russia
will it protect you if the price of
bread is paid in a wheelbarrow full of
banknotes so far the evidence is
contradictory on the one hand bitcoin's
price has almost no correlation with the
market-based measures of inflation
expectations
for instance while gold a known
inflation hedge has a near perfect
relationship with u.s bonds to track
inflation
bitcoin does not and while gold still
buys the same amount of stuff as it did
in the days of ancient rulers of babylon
bitcoin has only been around for little
over a decade
on the other hand for the brief period
that bitcoin has existed its purchasing
power certainly has risen
yes there were periods of spectacular
crashes where its value measured in u.s
dollars collapsed
but over time those who held on to the
cryptocurrency rather than actively
trading it were able to buy more and
more with it
in 2013
one bitcoin bought about half a barrel
of oil
in 2017 it bought 300.
last year you could get more than a
thousand barrels for a single bitcoin
now economists might warn that at a
macro level that's deflationary and
counterproductive for investment and
growth but for those hoarding bitcoin it
was obviously a great result
the jury is still out on whether this
will remain true in the long run but
until now at least bitcoin has proven a
great store of wealth even as it failed
to purely hedge inflation i'm eddie van
der waals this is decrypted for more
content like this follow us on your
favorite platforms